c'est au profit d'une autre cause celle
des enfants maltraités que le château de
versailles reçoit ce soir la princesse
de galles dîner de gala pour lady diana
suivi pas à pas tout l'après midi et
c'est un privilège par mary pierce
amitié et jean corti la princesse de
galles a quitté l'ambassade de grande
bretagne
aussitôt après le déjeuner pour se
rendre dans une crèche de vinyle montant
dans un quartier difficile de la
capitale venu en france à l'invitation
de la fondation pour l'enfance d'anne
aymone giscard d'estaing c'est diana qui
a choisi de se rendre dans cette crèche
blessé dans sa vie privée la princesse a
décidé de se tourner vers les enfants
notamment les enfants maltraités
déjà en septembre diana avait choisi de
jouer un rôle actif au sein de la croix
rouge britannique pour les enfants du
rwanda
cette visite à paris concorde avec sa
volonté de redorer son image de
princesse surtout en menant une vie
publique plus généreuse à la crèche
diana a caressé beaucoup de visages
d'enfants en toute simplicité
elle a même pris le thé avec les mamans
elle fait passer beaucoup d'affection
dans son contact avec beaucoup elle aime
le contact des enfants et les enfants le
sens ça m'a choqué de faire une pause
avec lady diana télé et les civils pas
de mentalité d'une princesse la paix la
photo du volontiers comment les
trouvez-vous
le protocole n'avait prévu qu'une
demi-heure latrèche finalement diana
n'est reparti au bout d'une heure
ensuite ni shopping ni emplettes chez
les grands couturiers
la princesse a décidé de rester sagement
à l'ambassade de grande bretagne avant
la grande soirée de gala ce soir en son
honneur au palais de versailles